I tested high in mycotoxins. What should I take to kill mold in my body? We've had these
questions a lot because it's a misunderstanding what a mycotoxin test is. If you do go back on
our website and look at our blog and search just the word mold and it's multiple blog posts about
mold and I go into detail in some videos and what mycotoxins are. I think that will help you.
But in short, a mycotoxin is a toxin that a mold produces. It's not mold itself. So when I do a
mycotoxin test, so I do a urine test. That's typically a mycotoxin test is when I test
high in mycotoxins. That does not mean I have molds in my body. So mold is a living organism.
It's a type of fungus. It's a living organism. A living organism will give off toxins. So if I
have a living fungus in my body, it's most commonly going to be in my lungs. And I can't have that,
but that's not my mycotoxin. That's not going to, you know, necessarily it's almost never going to
give a mycotoxin elevation in the person's urine. A mycotoxin is something that you pick up from
either eating foods that have mold in it. Let's say peanuts. Okay, peanuts are corn.
Pop corn. You know, corn is prone to having mold in it. And the molds produce mycotoxins,
and then we eat them and adjust them. And those mycotoxins circulate in our blood. They're
poisons. They're toxins. They're they're not living things. We can pick up mold. Mycotoxins very
commonly. We can pick up from moldy buildings. So we get molded in our house or breathing in these
mycotoxins. Mycotoxins are produced by that black mold that's growing in your bathroom. So
that we breathe those mycotoxins in. Mycotoxins are highly toxic. They're their carcinogens. Most of them
are our strong carcinogens. And they need to be dealt with. The mycotoxin test is a good test to
test for. And you have to deal with those mycotoxins and to detoxify them. So how do you
get rid of them? Well, you're not killing mold in your body. Again, you're getting your detoxing
these toxins called mycotoxins. So how do you detox any toxins? You support all the detoxification
pathways. Make sure that you're having daily movements. Make sure that your binding stuff
taking the binders or your binding stuff in the colons. You're not really absorbing it.
Making sure your your gallbladder is healthy. You use hot packs over your liver, gallbladder to
help with that. Make sure that you are phase one, phase two, phase three pathways in the liver are
open and healthy. Maybe getting a genetic test done to see the health of those would be beneficial.
And then you're starting to key late mycotoxins out of your body. You're using a key later to
grab out the things to pull it in to the bloodstream. And then when it goes into the blood of
estipose through the liver and hopefully you've dealt with the or are dealing with phase two, phase
three in the liver is going through the liver into the bile into the bile. It's going to the
smaller tested, smaller tested in the larger tested. Hopefully you're using the binders so that you're
not re-absorbing these things and that you're depositing them in the toilet. So the ultimate goal
of detoxification is getting stuff from your body into the toilet. So the more and the better
and the better rate of detoxification that is happening in your body, the better you're going to have
subsequent tests of toxins be closer to normal. But of course you have to address
you know the exposure. So if you're not addressing the exposure you could do everything that I just said
and if your rate of detoxification leading your exposure to toxins is greater than your ability
and your rate to get them out, well you're you're stuck with it. You're going to be sick puppy.
So you've got to deal with whatever we do with mycotoxin test,
on someone that's elevated, I always suggest you test your house for exposure because if you
got mold in your bathroom that you don't see, maybe it's behind the wall and you're breathing it in
all night while you're sleeping and every time you're in that part of the house, but you're just going
to kill yourself. So she's no way to detoxify it fast enough to make yourself better so you need to deal
with that.